i'm martha mccallum i'm bill hemmer i'm
shannon breme and this is the fox news
rundown
wednesday december 15 2021 i'm lisa
brady
kovid gets the blame often at the white
house but will democrats pay a high
price for inflation
looking at the inflation picture now it
only seems to be getting worse as
they're considering another bill so i do
think that this reverberates to the
president and no matter what they're
saying about covid it's real we speak
with fox's bret baer
i'm dave anthony it sets the deadly
michigan high school shooting apart from
others in the past the accused student
gunman and his parents are all in the
same jail the prosecutors have exercised
their discretion to charge him as an
adult
and they certainly have the discretion
under
michigan law to do that but then that
begs the question
why
charge the parents
and i'm dr nicole sapphire i've got the
final word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
covid has now claimed 800 000 lives in
the u.s and one year after vaccinations
began cases are rising again at a time
when the president's poll numbers keep
sinking people's psychology on the
economy on how they're experiencing
things in the country right now is
related to kovitz white house
spokeswoman jensaki reacting friday to a
monmouth university poll that found
two-thirds of americans believe the u.s
is on the wrong track and an abc ips's
poll finds just 28 percent to prove of
how president biden is handling
inflation as recent surveys also show
rising prices and everyday bills
surpassing the pandemic is the top
concern the president's number is also
dropping on other issues including crime
and covet we haven't seen a slide like
this in a long time
brett baier is chief political
correspondent for fox news and the host
of special report on fox news channel it
is contingent on a number of different
things but i really think it started
around the afghanistan withdrawal that
particular
movement and effort by the
administration and then the fallout from
it
started this competency question and it
started raising its head in different
polls
that's where the slide started but then
as it continues
i think it has more to do with inflation
and what people are paying
not only at the pump but at the grocery
store and every place else
what about the president's handling of
the economy because inflation is one of
many things that the white house seems
to kind of blame on covid or frustration
with kovid
on some level
but if people are hurting with the
higher prices you know who's the public
blaming
well it ultimately falls to whoever's in
charge and this president will be the
recipient of that
if it continues and i think it depends
the administration is suggesting that
you know 17 nobel laureates say that um
you know their build back better
plan and the trillions of dollars
they're putting into the economy
will not uh harm the inflation situation
but you heard democratic senator joe
manchin from west virginia say the 17
nobel laureates were wrong and looking
at the inflation picture now
it only seems to be getting worse as
they're considering another bill so i i
do think that this reverberates to the
president and no matter what they're
saying about covid it's real
yeah even though the senate majority
leader is still talking about a vote
before christmas senator manchin doesn't
seem ready to take the plunge and then
we have this alternative score from the
congressional budget office showing much
more debt if the proposed programs last
longer than what's proposed
is that resonating with the public or is
it too much in the weeds
i think for most americans they're not
down to that granular level they know
that it's a lot of money
we used to think that 800 billion for
the tarp the troubled asset relief
program
was a huge number and now we are into
the billions and billions and trillions
and uh you know we just went through 1.9
trillion for a coveted relief package
back in march uh the infrastructure bill
bipartisan effort passed
almost 2 trillion and now you're looking
at a bill that depending who you ask
could be three to six trillion dollars
with the t
so people i think look at it as a lot of
money
uh the political side of it is that the
administration tied the infrastructure
bill to this other build back better
bill
and if that one doesn't get through it's
going to be seen as a loss even though
the first one got through i remember
hearing along the way
during this long debate that
there were other moderate democrats not
satisfied with some of the provisions in
bill beck better
is it really just joe manson and kirsten
cinema at this point or are there in
fact others can they count on the rest
of the democrats in the senate right now
i think that's a great question manchin
has told me
that there are other democrats who are
kind of under his umbrella of concern
uh that outside of kirsten cinema from
arizona you know
i don't know but senator mark kelly from
arizona who's up for reelection
you know if if the bill is not looking
like it's coming together
he would be probably happier not to have
to vote on it
uh politically now
you know what people are going to say
publicly and what they say privately
sometimes in politics or two different
things
the president seems to be under mounting
pressure as well on rising crime
um can he actually do anything to curb
crime in cities though
well his messaging uh has has been
interesting to watch or at least the
white house is messaging gensake
at first
kind of blowing off the crime
issue uh a few weeks ago and then
coming back and saying you know we've
studied this and crime is in fact on the
rise in the number of big cities and
places across the country
but also pointing to covet as a reason
for that
not acknowledging that in some of these
places prosecutors failing to go after
criminals or releasing them immediately
is the recidivism that we're seeing in a
lot of places
um they're not ready for that messaging
and
you're right i mean a lot of it is
handled locally
i think the majority whip in the senate
dick durbin was asked about having a
hearing
and
his response was partly that well he'd
like to go a step further and maybe
actually have a markup on some proposals
but everything that he mentioned
was along the lines of gun control
which is interesting from a senator who
represents illinois and in part chicago
with some of the strictest gun laws in
the country
um
listen
it's you you can go down the gun road
and you
are not going to go far in this congress
the way it's split
as far as legislation that's going to
get through
you
there are a number of other things that
can happen about
funding police officers or
assisting um
from a federal level on that effort and
that has not happened as of yet
covet had been
a high note for president biden for a
long time but he's getting
low marks for that now in the polls as
well and again the white house blames
frustration with covid for a lot of
other low numbers but is that a valid
argument
covet is you know
it's tough to say how it plays
politically i do think that there's a
backlash to a lot of the strict
restrictions that we're seeing
considering that we have vaccines we
have boosters
uh we have now a pill from pfizer
and
others who say that it's very effective
and is going to come be coming out soon
they say
uh so
there is some thought that you know any
sort of lockdown or mandates
uh there will be pushback too and it's
not just republicans it's democrats as
well and you're starting to see that and
and because of that how the
administration talks about it really
matters and they're they're seeing some
backlash
while all of these issues circulate the
house committee probing the capital riot
continues its work issuing subpoenas and
launching contempt cases against former
trump administration officials for not
complying most recently former white
house chief of staff mark meadows who
stopped cooperating last week he told
fox's sean hannity the committee is
really just out to get the former
president this is not about me holding
me in contempt it's not even about
making the capital safer we see that by
some of the selective leaks that are
going on right now this is about donald
trump and about actually going after him
once again wyoming congresswoman liz
cheney one of two republicans on the
committee insists it's an objective
search for the truth we as republicans
used to be unified
on this point in terms of what happened
on january 6th
and the responsibility the president had
to stop it but what about voters who
aren't far left or far right have they
already moved on
i think there's a lot of people who want
to move on uh i do think that
you know there is this sense that the
january 6 committee is going to get to
the bottom of what was happening
at the white house in communication with
different congress members
and in essence they're going to have
this this moment where this report comes
out and obviously it's not going to look
good politically
one would guess
for
some members of congress and perhaps for
the former president
um but this
you know it would have been a lot easier
had
republicans um
not just liz cheney
and
kenziger
if there had been a mccarthy buy-in
uh the minority leader buy-in to this
committee i think there would have been
a little bit less of this partisan back
and forth over it they're going to do
their job they're going to come to the
end there's going to be report
and there's going to be political
recrimination and then on the other side
there's going to be you know charges
that it was all ginned up so i think
that's going to follow the the blueprint
but along the way we're probably going
to find out some information that we
didn't know before
and you have the
the midterms really
looming in the in the not too distant
future i mean now we're less than a year
away
are republicans in danger at this point
of counting their chickens before
they're hatched
um
based on the president's poll numbers
i think they feel pretty confident i
think they in the house feel like they
can paint by numbers and pick up the
seats they need
there's already seats that the census is
essentially giving them
extra seats in red
places um i think that
there's a feeling that they can get over
that number and likely have
many more the senate is a bigger
question and a lot more can happen
in the 10 months that we'll see ahead
what do you think or maybe none of them
but what if any of these issues
covet inflation the january 6th
committee crime
um
if any of those issues changes
substantially do you think that would
change the outlook for the midterms
well if um inflation changes and the
economic picture changes for people
sitting at home
yes if the motivations for voting change
for independents and maybe frustrated
democrats but other issues um you know
how
this administration is handling foreign
affairs the lingering
um
efforts about and concerns about
afghanistan the southern border
immigration especially for those border
states will be a big issue
and then crime is the issue that gets
across all
different ideologies and
all different
uh demographics because if you don't
feel safe
in and about your city or your state
that is a motivator a big one for going
to the polls
we certainly appreciate you being on top
of all of it bret baer fox news chief
political correspondent and the host of
special report with bret baer on the fox
news channel thank you very much for
coming on the rundown you bet
[Music]
this is dr nicole sapphire with your fox
news commentary coming up
they came to court in shackles from the
same michigan jail where their 15 year
old son is also being held
james and jennifer crumbly had a
probable cause hearing on different
charges than ethan who is up for murder
attempted murder and terrorism in the
oxford high school shooting two weeks
ago accused of killing four of his
fellow students and wounding six others
and a teacher it is
causing great distress among our whole
agency
that this happened and
that
there was an opportunity potentially to
prevent it oakland county sheriff mike
bouchard the crumbly parents were in
school earlier the day of the shooting
to discuss ethan's behavior and violent
messages and drawings gun owners have a
responsibility prosecutor karen mcdonald
charged the parents with involuntary
manslaughter that a parent
could read those words and also know
that their son had access to a deadly
weapon
that they gave him
is unconscionable but andy mccarthy says
this case is virtually unheard of i have
to say virtually because there are one
or two cases over the years but it's
almost never the case
that the parents are charged mccarthy is
a former federal prosecutor now a fox
news contributor
there are two related decisions it seems
to me that they're related that have
been made here one is
that they have decided to treat the 15
year old who actually
did the shooting we have to say
allegedly at this point but this is not
one of those cases where there's a lot
of doubt about what happened the
prosecutors have exercised their
discretion to charge him as an adult
and they certainly have the discretion
under uh michigan law to do that
but then that begs the question
why
charge the parents if you're going to
charge the kid as an adult then you're
claiming that he had the agency and the
responsibility
to in committing this crime and should
be treated and prosecuted as if he were
an adult independent actor so andy is
that something if you are
the defense attorneys for the parents is
that your number one defense they're
charged with involuntary manslaughter is
that the number one case you have
i think dave that the best case that the
lawyers for the parents have
is that under
michigan law
and what the jury would be instructed
with respect to involuntary manslaughter
the government can't prove the case
beyond a reasonable doubt because it's
not enough
that they acted irresponsibly
and even negligently under michigan law
the
the result here the shooting
has to be the natural and necessary
outcome from the act of negligence
where's the line here because they
allege that this gun was purchased not
long before the shooting and their and
the prosecutor alleges that it is the
gun owner's responsibility
to not allow the gun to get into the
hands of a minor that way especially
because they say the parents knew
that he had these violent
thoughts or whatever used cartoons or
images or threats or whatever you want
to say about them that that they say
that maybe there is a
you could take that step potentially the
problems that they're going to have with
that argument
are
twofold one is
the
legislature in michigan has had proposed
a number of times what are known as cap
laws this uh child access prevention
laws
with respect to firearms that have been
enacted in some states michigan
has elected not to enact it so to the
extent the prosecutors are saying it was
unlawful for
the parents
not to uh
make sure that the kid could not get
access to the gun
they've they've proposed making that a
crime in michigan but they haven't so
it's up to the legislature to make
to make things criminal the prosecutor
can't do that the prosecutor can only
enforce the laws that the legislature
has enacted and the other thing that the
uh that the prosecutors say is that the
only way that you can uh safely
uh put a gun away if you're the adult is
to uh lock the gun
in a container uh with a clip on it that
makes it uh a safety clip that that
makes it not fireable and keep the
ammunition away from it that may be the
opinion of the prosecutor but there's
nothing in michigan law that says that
that is the case
now for the average person the parents
did not turn themselves in
there was a manhunt they were found
hiding in a detroit warehouse
that doesn't look to the average person
like someone who's innocent right
it doesn't and it would be the kind of
evidence that would be very damning in a
lot of cases
uh it's called uh prosecutors refer to
it the law refers to it as consciousness
of guilt evidence in other words you
know if you're innocent uh you you don't
usually flee
um that's uh
the sort of thing a normal person
wouldn't do so it's often
very powerful
evidence for a jury
i don't know that it will have the same
power
in this instance the parents defense
is really a legal one
not a factual one i don't think they're
going to be saying
i'm not guilty because i didn't do this
what they're going to say is that these
things that i did
as a matter of law do not amount to
involuntary
manslaughter in michigan and if that's
their defense then the consciousness of
guilt evidence if they go forward if
they're allowed by the court to go
forward with it
won't be very persuasive
all right let's take this a step further
andy
can the school district be held
responsible now there have been lawsuits
filed
and in one case the parents of a 17 year
old student who was shot in the neck and
wounded now they believe teachers and
they believe counselors and
administrators should be held
responsible their attorney jeffrey
feiger claims that they they could have
easily prevented what happened and i
want you to hear what he has to say
about that he was
drawing photographs of mayhem they were
aware of posts on the internet
indicating that he was intending to
commit mayhem he drew pictures uh
indicating uh that he was going to
engage in a murderous rage again that's
feiger talking about the accused gunman
the 15 year old what do you think
i think they should all be subject to to
civil liability but other than the fact
that the you know the parents were aware
that the that the gun had been purchased
whereas the school officials weren't and
i'm not suggesting that that's not a
significant distinction it obviously is
but the theory of prosecuting the
parents is the same one that you would
have if you were to decide to indict the
school officials which is that their
negligence was profound and it led
foreseeably
to the ultimate conclusion of the of the
mass shooting attack so i don't like the
idea of the criminal law being extended
that way the criminal law is prosecuting
the shooter as it should
uh and he's being prosecuted he's gonna
have multiple life sentences here he's a
15 year old who's being treated as an
adult who probably will never ever
be out of confinement let's get into
that case against the 15 year old ethan
crumbly he had his uh probable cause
hearing moved to uh early january he is
facing four counts of murder and of
course he's accused of wounding seven
others
you had already said that it seems
pretty clear-cut does he
do you think go on some sort of a a
mental state defense
i really don't see what else there could
conceivably be dave now i i wouldn't
want to say for sure that you go down
that road
unless
all the preliminaries are done so he'll
have to be examined and he'll get
examined by his own uh
psychologist psychiatrists in the in the
states
and they'll make
an assessment
but as far as like the normal criminal
law evidence
which require proof beyond a reasonable
doubt of the criminal act which is the
murder and the criminal state of mind
which they seem to have immense evidence
of uh premeditation here given the the
media the social media postings and the
like
it looks like the case
you know there's a difference between
how horrific it is
versus how difficult it is to prove it
looks like it's a layup to
to prove it
anybody who's 15 years old and if he did
draw those cartoons and he was
going through all those violent images
in his head and and then he finally you
know acts it out
that he's not right right there's
nothing that's not a right mind well
you know yes but think about it any case
involving a horrific crime
you know i had i tried terrorists in
the 1990s
and
you know one of the defendants wanted to
suggest that the crime the idea of mass
murdering people in the kind of attack
that was uh was being plotted was so
beyond the pale of uh the the horror of
human imagination that only someone not
in his right mind
could
conceivably uh come up with it and be
responsible for it if you buy the logic
of that argument then the more horrific
a crime is the less we can hold people
accountable for it so
what the criminal law in
terms of criminal intent requires
is proof that the person understood the
rightness or wrongness
of his actions
and acted intentionally which means
acted not by mistake
uh and if you can prove that you you
have proven
criminal intent it's a very high bar to
prove that you lack mental capacity to
commit an offense you really have to
show
that the kid didn't know the difference
between right and wrong
but i just think it's a very difficult
proof
you referenced the terror case that
you'd worked on in in the past
there are charges of terrorism in this
school shooting a different
level of proof there
yeah and i think it's a real mistake to
bring those
charges i don't understand i i mean i
understand
as a political gesture
why the
government and the prosecutor's office
would want to do that as attack the kids
were traumatized and terrorized right by
someone shooting up their classrooms and
they were hiding yeah but in fear
i don't think that this qualifies
as terrorism under the michigan
statute but my
my big
problem with it
is not
the idea of
of bringing it because you're
distinguishing
um
a group at school
versus the public at large which is what
terrorism is normally directed at my
problem with what the prosecutors are
doing here is why do it
that you already have with the with the
very serious murder and attempted murder
charges
you already have much more criminal
exposure than you could ever need to
keep this kid neutralized and
institutionalized
for the rest of his life and to the
extent that you want to raise terrorism
that's something that can always be
raised at sentencing there's no reason
to complicate the uh what should be a
very straightforward criminal trial with
that kind of stuff which only is going
to
make exactly the issue that you raised a
couple of minutes ago more pertinent
which is his state of mind
andy mccarthy former federal prosecutor
fox news contributor always good to get
your insight on a case thank you so much
thanks dave appreciate it
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network i'm
ben dominic publisher of the federalists
and i'm inviting you to join a new
conversation with the smartest thinkers
out there about the country and where
we're going subscribe to the ben dominic
podcast subscribe and listen now by
going to foxnewspodcasts.com
subscribe to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com
it's time for your fox news commentary
dr nicole sapphire
what's on your mind the concept of zero
covid once perhaps a realistic ambition
is now a delusion as variants continue
traveling the world circulating among
humans and animals thankfully the
initial waves of the pandemic the
devastating stages of intense
transmission with a high rate of
consequent severe illness
are over for most of the country this
doesn't mean the virus is gone or that
transmission is low
rather the pandemic is moving into the
next phase becoming endemic it is almost
certain the covet 19 pandemic will
evolve similar to the 1918 influenza
virus
a century ago a novel strain of
influenza killed more than 50 million
people worldwide the virus did not
disappear
the virus continued to mutate
with seasonal outbreaks from milder
variants further dampened by vaccines
and treatments
sound familiar
it is too early to be certain but the
newest variant of concern omicron may be
the path to making this virus endemic if
health officials would only let it
early data on omicron show that cases
are rising among the vaccinated and
unvaccinated but milder symptoms are
being reported in both groups nearly two
years since the first case of covet 19
was reported in wuhan the combination of
lesson virulence natural immunity
vaccinations and updated treatment
protocols have reduced the harm of this
virus to end the hysteria public health
officials must communicate effectively
accurate metric driven data with advice
not mandates on risk reduction
strategies rather than media hyped
conjecture this past week headlines
emphasize the pfizer ceo suggesting a
fourth dose of vaccine may be necessary
this may be true for high-risk
individuals with an annual coveted
booster eventually being recommended
similar to the flu shot
however the current conversation
surrounding boosters is myopic and
premature
also americans shouldn't be getting
public health updates from big pharma
boosting the younger healthier
populations now may be delaying the
virus from becoming endemic
allowing the virus to run its course has
never been a public health strategy as
it is risky and will lead to preventable
death
however
the coveted vaccines are still
protecting against severe disease and
shortening the length of illness
permitting milder infection to circulate
will only increase population immunity
the addition of natural immunity from
prior covet 19 infection in a vaccinated
person provides robust long-term
protection more so than vaccine-induced
immunity alone as suggested in the siren
study looking at over 30 000 healthcare
workers in the uk
data from the cdc showed the risk of
hospitalization from covid after
vaccination to be about 1 in 26 000
to put that in perspective the lifetime
odds of dying in a car crash on the way
to work are one in 107 that's according
to the national safety council
future action should focus on reducing
covet hospitalizations while permitting
mild illness to circulate this can be
done through vaccination and healthy
lifestyle choices
while boosting anyone who wants it but
especially high-risk individuals and
their close contacts
it is time to get back to living life
without generalized mask wearing and
vaccine cards
americans are ready to show their smiles
and shake hands again
this is nicole sapphire i'm a fox news
contributor and assistant professor at
memorial sloan kettering cancer center
and wow cornell medical college
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network
subscribe and listen to the proud
american podcast hosted by marine corps
vet and fox news contributor johnny joey
jones subscribe and listen now by going
to foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes